[音楽]
大きな壁
あるところに
おじいさんが住んでいました
おじいちゃんは
よく
山へ
や3位を獲りに
お出かけていました
おじいちゃんはの今日も山の中で
いい野菜はないかいい野菜はないかと探していました
演技じゃねーぞを税さんが山を抜けて海の方を見ると
そこには
とんでもない光景が
なんと
今までに見たこともないような
大きな株があったのです
おじいさんは湖水かという設定を忘れてダッシュで下部に書き上げました
ん
[音楽]
株やないかいこれ言ったら仮になるべそう思ったおじいさんがすぐに株を抜こうとし
ましたが
王子来て一人の使うでは抜くことができませんでした
そこでおじいさんは
この海の近くで手伝ってくれる人を探しました
第ガーン
すると一人の村人が手伝いに来てくれましたーーー
彼の走った風圧でおじいさんの日は a に取れてしまいました
のうんと細どっこいしょ
まだまだカブは抜けませんさらに
手伝ってくれる人を探していると村人がもう一人
お手伝いに来てくれました風が抜けんのじゃ
n
うんとこそどっこいそ
まだまだ株アヌよねー
ほんと大丈夫ですよね3人わーさらに
手伝ってくれる人を探しました
[音楽]
少し恥ずかしいおじいさんでしたおじいちゃんは月で株を抜きたいと思い色々な人に声
をかけましたがみんなにガン無視でしか
を抜いてくれませんかまだ諦めるが早い
町立谷塚
ふざけ財株の契約おおきなかぶを抜こうとしても
基本的に誰も手伝ってくれません参議院はカバンの後行きたい一生懸命ドンカットルク
を受けました
食べかけのじゃ
大きな金が抜けませ声をかけることを10分
が付いた使う現代の文明の値がございましたおじいさんま自分のツイッターを使って皆
に募集をかけました
すみません
ブーバーン
と思っていた時一人の女どこも手伝いに来てくれました
ちょっと各壁抜いてもらっていいですかん
きっと細どっこいしょ
まだまだ株は付けばねぇ
結局その後おじいさんは40分待ったのですがみんなと写真撮影をして暗くなってきた
のでみんなが帰ってしまい一人になってしまいました
おしまいフ
me
[音楽]
パパッ